what do you do before a lift and what is
the inside of your head like before
you're about to put 1000 pounds on you
back in a meet it's it's really focused
and I go to a dark dark place in my head
where I don't care about anything else
and the last thing I want in the world
to happen when I'm under the bar is to
miss the lifts and embarrass myself so
everything is extremely tight I
visualize and see the lift being
completed effortlessly before I even
approach the platform I already see it
happen I see the crowds reaction and I
strive for that feeling to happen before
it even happens so I get out there and I
just go to my default mode I tune
everything out I tuned everyone out I go
and lift and I fight for my life for a
couple seconds then I put it back down
then I try to breathe and relax so you
turn it on you turn it off you turn it
on you turn it off punk fighter UFC
fighter between rounds you got a chill
breathe and relax then you go you turn
it back on and you relax
I'm joined by without a doubt the
strongest man that I have ever had on
this podcast mr. Brian Carol welcome the
show thank you for having me Chris oh I
appreciate it I'm looking forward to
having a chat with you yeah me too
recently had mutual friend of ours dr.
stuart mcgill on the show and he was
singing your praises and we also briefly
discussed the work that you two did
together so I'm excited to hear the
other side of that story as we get
through today yes it's been a very
interesting journey the last six years
that I've known dr. McGill and I met him
in May of 2013 where I went to see him
for a very complicated back injury that
I had the actual injury was basically
had no disc at l4 l5 l5 s1 it was
flattened just the same at l5 l4 l5 l5
s1 the but the discs were gone and had a
couple endplate fractures working down
to the sacrum where it was almost split
in half so I was in a bad spot where
surgeons were wanting to do a spinal
fusion on me they were talking all this
crazy stuff about how I'd never be out
of pain and stew right away he said that
I can get you out of pain but your
lifting is done you have absolutely no
athleticism left in your back and I'm
telling you this as if you were my son I
would urge you to retire and never
consider lifting heavy again and I said
well you just said that you could help
get me out of pain so I looked at him
and I looked at my wife and I barely
calmly said I'm gonna lift again so
let's get me out of pain and he said
well you know my thoughts on this first
things first let's get you out of pain
and then we'll proceed you come back in
six months we'll see where you are and
then who knows maybe you're right maybe
we end up writing a book about it and
that was the first meeting that we had
May of 2013 and we wrote the book in
2017 and I held him to his feet to the
fire when he said this and it's it have
you ever heard the phrase
factors stranger than fiction mm-hmm
it's super true man some stories that I
could tell you you'd be like how does
that even happen how does a guy from how
do two men from totally different worlds
one in the lab clinic training center
one from in the hole-in-the-wall
powerlifting gym how do they merge and
write a book that helps people all over
the world so it's a pretty awesome story
I'm looking forward to getting to it
today and I'm sure that a lot of the
listeners will be as well so can you
give us a little bit of a background to
your powerlifting career where where you
got yourself to in the build-up to this
and some of your achievements yeah so I
started I did my first bench competition
in 1999 when I was a senior in high
school we just actually had our 20-year
reunion for high school this past
weekend so I'm feeling kind of old
I just turned 38 I just turned 38 last
week but I started when I was 17 and I
actually got really serious about
lifting when I was 16 when I was legally
able to join the the local gym so from
there
I just fell in love with lifting I
didn't party in high school all I did
was lift eat well and run and I played
baseball so that was kind of my
prerequisite to taking this to the next
level once I graduated I didn't know
what the hell I wanted to do so what I
did is I kept working my sales job at
coca-cola and I just lifted I lifted it
lifted I did some bodybuilding for a
little bit I kept competing and
powerlifting and then finally the the
bug fully bit me in 2003 where I did my
first full competition meet which
consists of the squat the bench the dead
live for total so I did that and early I
started training for that in early 2002
the 2003 that was it man
that's all I thought about for the next
15 20 years it was just you know and
it's still that way but I've gotten a
little bit more mature with my approach
to lifting my patients because coming up
it didn't take long until I hit some big
big numbers that within three and a half
years I've cut my first full meet
competition I squatted a thousand 30 at
220 which broke the all-time world
record held by Chuck Vogel pull of
Westside barbell no one saw it coming so
here I am a kid at 25 years old break
this world record the next thing you
know I think I'm untouchable I think I'm
Superman
I end up going up a couple weight
classes setting records there 1185 squat
at 275 and 2011 but that lift cost me
you know I had a number
time at number two total Everett 220
number two total at 242 multiple times
in a number to total all time at 275 but
after a while that cumulative trauma of
abusing my body meat after meat after me
and not necessarily investing back into
my body after each competition I kind of
became physically in some ways mentally
bankrupt because I was pushing pushing
pushing and you see people whether it be
CrossFit whether it be fighting
wrestling powerlifting Olympic lifting
bodybuilding you have to have wrists you
have to have down time and one of my
good friends is arguably the best
bodybuilder of all time Dexter Jackson
he takes a lot of downtime every year he
just won the Tampa Pro and he's he's
actually in line to win the Olympia this
year with shawn rhoden pulling out KY
greens and I competed Phil Heath isn't
competing it's wide open so do you know
how L Dijkstra is he's 49 he'll be 50 on
Thanksgiving November that money's a
beast so but I've learned from him take
time off come off supplementation don't
train so hard to give your body a rest
so you become hungry once again to do it
and unfortunately I didn't always have
that approach and my body got badly
beaten up how would you describe your
training style in those years when you
were getting yourself up towards a
thousand pound and then moving from the
thousand 35 to like the eleven
forty-five squat and stuff like that
yeah so the 1185 where I ended up yeah
every pound counts there alone yes true
you fought hard for them it was whatever
it took whatever it took it did not
matter I trained whether I felt good or
not I didn't always listen to my body
what guy alluded to earlier I thought I
was Superman I thought I could do
everything when they look do every and
anything without any consequence and
after a while everyone's humid we've
seen it we see it every every field
eventually you slow down add extra
slowed down some he didn't want to
pressure for three years and this is his
first pro win in a while so we all
slowed down so what we had to do is
become more cerebral as we get older as
our lifting age our lifting age and
biological age are two different things
I know many people that just started
lift
Hevy at 40 years old they don't have the
miles that I have on my body even though
they're older than me from a biological
standpoint so it was reckless it was
heavy it was pushing at all costs now
I've kind of developed a little better
philosophy over the last six or seven
years where a skill training back I have
programmed D loads where I take
lightweight every few weeks if I don't
fill up to a lift one day I'll ask
myself it might be in a coward or am I
being smart and I'll weigh all my
options if something bills off and it
starts to feel better maybe I keep going
or if it fills off I shut it down and
just help the other guys for that day so
I'm a lot more cerebral these days and I
have to credit dr. McGill for a lot of
that because he helped he helped me a
great deal yeah I can hear the narrative
the Stewart narrative seeping through in
some of the words that you say and I
like I'm doing the same right I went to
go and spend a day with dr. McGill very
fortunately in Canada a couple of weeks
ago and I did my podcast with him and
we've been in touch a lot over email and
stuff like that and I find myself
drinking the kool-aid or singing from
the same hymn sheet now as well because
it appears to be the right one and I
want to get on to the whole the whole
ethos behind your engineering your
recovery and stuff like that but there
will be some big fan power lifters out
there who want to know what sort of
split you were doing in the build-up to
your main meet in the I guess the heyday
of your comp prep and stuff like that
can you take us through the typical sort
of day and who was programming for you
what were you eating etc etc good okay
so it all depended on what what weight
class size lives in that I lifted at 220
240 to 275 and even 308 benchpress range
so it really depends on what weight
class I was lifting at after a while I
got really big for the 220 class and so
I had to go up to 242 and then that
allowed me to eat a little bit more so
at the end of the day it comes down to
calorie consumption and your timing your
timing is to me important you need to
eat enough but not too much where you
store body fat so at times I've
experimented I've eaten too much I've
gotten fatter but with powerlifting it's
tricky because it isn't about
looks good it's about the person who's
most functional and strong at that time
so just like the whole mobility
flexibility thing for powerlifting is
you need enough but not too much it's
the same thing with body fat you don't
want too much body fat where you go up a
weight class or you're unhealthy but at
the same time when you start talking
about lower than 12% body fat your
joints end up getting a little bit less
supported you have less fluid in them
your core becomes smaller which your
trunk is the pillar of strength that
that is the catalyst to two big lifts
you oddly shop lettuce ISM through a
stiff proximal core and it leads to
distal mobility throughout the the
shoulders and hips now that is straight
out of the doctor make your book that is
that is his voice you even said it in a
Canadian accent I think naturally yes I
did so basically right now I'm still
gonna train for competition right now
I'm taking time off and very fortunately
I just got my blood work back and I am
completely healthy in every way my
cholesterol my kidneys my liver my heart
everything came back is is good and
really good on some things my overall
cardiac risk was like off-the-charts low
so that's a good thing after all this
heavy lifting congratulations
yeah thank you so I'm gonna probably
pick back up in 2020 for some
competitions and there's still some
numbers that I'd like to hit I like that
get that 1200 pound squat in because
1185 is 1200 but it's not quite 1200
pounds there's only been 10 men never
squat 1,200 pounds ever Wow
and they're all over 300 pounds so you
could centrally be the lightest month
yes if you trying to do that to 80 to 85
I would probably try to do that 275 yeah
Oh 125 kilo so right now my diet
consists of a lot of steak a lot of rice
a lot of spinach carrots Greek yogurt
oranges orange juice and whole eggs
that's really what I eat now and I think
it's a my blood works a testament to to
eating the right foods you can still be
big and strong and healthy at the same
time but in the past
I would be on the seafood diet whatever
I saw I ate I ate I love to eat I love
junk food so that's something I've been
working on as well as just scaling back
to junk food and not feeding my brain
those happy feelings by eating getting
to serotonin or whatever it is it
releases when you eat you know a big
piece of pie or a big piece of cake or a
big bowl of ice cream I've gotten better
about that but my overall philosophy is
eat eat for performance eat to perform
and whatever fuels your body to lift the
best is what you need to eat and that's
gonna range a lot from different people
I think stand efforting is vertical diet
is a great great diet for the strength
athlete and it he'll I've been following
it and my health is better than ever - I
eat a lot of red meat cholesterol HDL
went up LDL went down imagine that
triglycerides people are scared to read
me and I don't really think that it's uh
it's the poison that a lot of people
think now for some people maybe they
respond poorly to starchy carbs like
rice and you know a high-fat meat like
like red meat or ground beef but for me
it works really well so that's been my
I've always liked to eat a lot of
stickin sorry
steak chicken fish shrimp and then rice
pasta oatmeal for my carbs and then I've
always like spinach squash carrots to
get my micros in and then I like to
supplement with some vitamin D I'll take
some fiber to make sure everything's you
know nice and cleaned out and fish a
little so other than that man I that's
really the basis of what I've uses my
diet overall and then if I feel myself
leaning out too much I'll add more
calories I'll add more carbs and fat
usually the protein stays about the same
and then you know depending on where my
body weight is it might be more carbs
and fat or less carbs and fat and I use
the mirror to be that indicator for me
that's not necessarily the scale but I
can't disregard the scale because I
lived in a weight class so there's a lot
of variables there now as far as my
training split what I've found works
best for me and it was corroborated by
Stu's wisdom is I like to squat and
deadlift on day one there's a couple
reasons
for that it allows me a full week of
recovery before I squat or deadlift
again so I have to worry about squatting
Saturday and then deadlifting Wednesday
then having to turn around and squat
again on Saturday so that's been
something I've done for the better part
of the last 12 years or so but it really
hit home when Stu taught me you need to
give yourself at least 5 days in between
loading so they want a squat and
deadlift with a little bit of assistance
day 2 is off day 3 is bench press and
bench press assistance day 4 is off
which is Tuesday Wednesday is squat and
deadlift assistance so I'll do my my
hamstring work my quad work my upper
back work my mid-back work my bicep work
and then I take Thursday off after that
day and then Friday I do a little bit of
a pump workout where I just get some
blood flowing I'll do a little bit of
slight dragging and cardio and carries
which I do at the end of each workout
but it's more of a focal point on Friday
and that kind of gets me ready and the
blood flow in for Saturday water and
when I squat and deadlift again
interesting four days a week and that's
not rotation yep yeah and then every
three or four weeks I take a lighter a
week on the main movement so I might
only work up to 50 percent of what I'm
capable of that day and that's why I
think a sliding scale something like RPE
the rate of rate of perceived exertion
or effort however you want to put it I
think it's good because depending on
what you have going on in your life the
weights are gonna fluctuate you can't
always go off with percentages what if
you're on a honeymoon and you're in
Jamaica and the weight room is not up to
snuff you're gonna have to scale back
the weights you use if you're only going
on percentages it's gonna lead to a lot
of disappointment eventually so what you
do is you look at what you're capable of
today then work off of that max what you
feel like you have in a tank that day so
a lot of the time every three or four
weeks I'll just work at like a 5 RPE or
50% of what I'm capable of that day and
just do singles so I reiterate those
engrams of perfect form every single
time so it gives me not only a refresher
for my brain but a refresher for my body
and then I'm ready you know I'm a little
more motivated to get back onto the bar
with heavier weight the following weeks
and what I'd like to do is take a light
week before you're absolutely crippled
and forced to take a light week because
then we know that overtraining can last
up to a month for some people they're
over stimulated they might get sick they
might not sleep well they they might
have a regression in their strength achy
the flu there's a lot of symptoms that
come and come along with training too
hard for too long and I've been there
multiple times you just everything feels
like crap you become depressed
everything's heavy so why not stay ahead
of that wave before it crashes on you
why not write it like a surfer hmm yeah
one of the things that you touched on
earlier on that made me think something
I know a lot of athletes that are
listening will consider which is how
much of my not unwillingness to train
but my concern about the session that I
have in front of me or the difficulty
that I'm finding in this session how
much of that is because I am my current
makeup is not in a very optimal state
I've understad time not eaten very well
I might be getting the onset of a book
and how much of that is me being a [ __ ]
how much of that do I need to push
through and that line is it's very
difficult to define around I'm gonna
guess that even more so in a sport like
power lifting where spit and sawdust
guys like Lois Simmons Westside Barbra
you know get it done yeah how how do you
how do you make that judgment and how do
you swallow the ego
whenever I figure it out I'll do another
part because it's ever it's a it's a
it's a constant battle to figure that
out and you know what you can read all
these text books you can read my book
1020 life you can read give into the
injury ultimate back fitness and
performance so on and so forth back
mechanic but until you understand the
art of coaching and application all that
knowledge is crap it's useless so I say
that to tell you it's about the art it's
the art of knowing your body and paying
attention to indicators indicators
meaning physical mental psychological
spiritual whatever you have going on
you've got to say
is the juice worth the squeeze today am
i close to a competition do I really
need these lifts yes okay let's push a
little bit
hey I'm 12 weeks out from a meet I don't
need to go heavy today I'm gonna shut it
down maybe I'll come back tomorrow and
feel a little bit better my girlfriend
just broke up with me I didn't sleep all
night because the neighbours were
fighting you know I didn't eat good
today because you know my child was sick
at school so it's there's gonna be a lot
of things and not everything is gonna be
optimal every single time but with that
said I think preparation beforehand
having your food cooked in case you
can't you know run and cook your food or
go home and get it no in places where
you can get your food while you're out
to eat and always staying up to date on
your sleep and not and not staying up
all night every night and you know get
on a schedule because that's important a
lot of people seem to think that it
needs to be regimen and every single day
so that means getting in bed at 10
o'clock or 11 o'clock and sleep until 6
or 7 and doing that every single day
which will get your body in a nice nice
rhythm there but I've still yet to
optimize my sleep I like to stay up late
man I like to read I like to research I
like to see what's going on man and the
thing about being up late is no one's
gonna bother you you know no one's gonna
bother you do your research I like to
read study and that's a problem for
recovery though yeah naturally I'm a
night owl as well I recently read a blog
post saying that people have a genetic
predisposition to being early Birds or
night owls and that's really quite
difficult to to flip around or live I've
worked as hard as I can
to get myself on that the same like
daily cadence as everyone else but it's
I'm still bouncing off that limit or a
little bit another thing that came to
mind when you were talking about routine
and routines their blog posts from Ryan
holiday which I've discussed on the
podcast before which is very so that you
don't need a routine you need a number
of routines and he talks about how he
has his I'm away on a book tour routine
when he's in a unoptimized hotel room
and there's a blinking light over the
far side and it's not quiet and it's
this than the other but he can he's
realized I need an eye mask
I need earplugs and he
etc etc and you're saying the same it's
okay yeah what you have this particular
day coming up and overtime a little bit
of experience will show you that you
need to prepare better for this I need
to have my food prep for the full day
not just for lunch I need to make sure
I've got water because I'm gonna be
driving a long journey or whatever it
might be all that stuff and yeah that
comes across with experience right which
is obviously what you've been able to
tap into now yeah and that stuff isn't
gonna come from a book it's gonna come
from experience and I wish I knew back
then what I know now that we all say
that whether it be about relationships
whether it be about nutrition about high
school whatever it may be and I
mentioned high school because I just had
my 20-year reunion and it's definitely
interesting the perspective that I have
now versus back then yes so it's it's
all about preparation and that's that's
gonna give you the most likely chance of
success and that's being prepared also
being flexible being able to roll with
the punches because not everything not
everything is gonna be gonna go your way
and it's very frustrating and I've
struggled with that too so you have to
toe the line of being an absolute
control freak and also being able to go
with the flow which is it's like saying
I want I want my food super hot but at
the same time I want it super cold it's
impossible so you got to optimize you
got to pick your battles I get it so
many people that are listening may have
seen powerlifting they'll know what it
is squat bench and deadlift those three
lifts but there's kind of two broads
leagues of powerlifting I guess you
could call it in being equipped and
unequipped is that fair to say very fair
so back in the days of let's say Bill
Kazmaier
he's the guy that wrote the foreword for
gift of injury great strength athlete I
don't know if you saw but we had Swiss
last year and Mississauga Canada and we
had a powerlifting panel with myself Jim
when Larry jail holdsworth Ken Wed um ed
cone and Bill Kazmaier
yeah big names and we had some great
talks you know Bill wore what he could
back in the day and that was a very not
very helpful squat suit a Spanish knee
wraps they'd wear tiny t-shirts to help
them benchpress more so it's evolved
over the years the benchpress shirt was
advert invented in the 80s and what that
did initially was help protect the pecs
in the shoulders from heavy bench
presses eventually it's evolved where
the gear helps a lot more than it used
to so now what you have is the belts the
knee wraps and the sleeves that give
supportive give support to the the you
know the elbows the knees and the core
they are way more beyond anything that
was going on in the 70s and 80s and even
90s so with technology everything
evolves so in 2006 everyone lifted
equipped there weren't people that
lifted raw because you'd be bringing a
knife to a gunfight basically you would
be you'd be very overwhelmed and only
people that lifted raw without equipment
were the people that couldn't quite
figure out their equipment because
there's an art to them to it it isn't
just about putting equipment on and
lifting big weights you have to
acclimate your central nervous system to
that heavier load to that extra hundred
pounds on the squat that you can't live
without the suit so it's it's a it's an
art to it you have to be strong in and
outside of the suit and that's a
balancing act
so once what the the raw movement hit in
2006 a lot of people started lifting
without peril it's in gear or just
wearing wraps and sleeves and a belt
without the suit and they call that raw
but it's not really raw unless you're
not using anything right because I've
know people who get 50 pounds out of a
belt they get 150 pounds out of a tight
knee wrap and then you know so on and so
forth but it's kind of it kind of had a
big split back in 2006 because their
their first official raw meat the New
England record breakers up in
Massachusetts and then a lot of people
started getting into the sport because
the gear turned them off because it's a
lot of work you have to have people
there helping them so shortly after the
birth of raw powerlifting CrossFit
started coming over and competing a lot
in powerlifting and so that made
powerlifting explode but the Koala
it kind of went to the wayside it wasn't
as sticked into competitions and he had
a lot of beginner level strict athletes
coming into powerlifting and his
CrossFitters they're not going to wear
the gear so that's how powerlifting raw
kind of took over the last 10 - 10 - 10
to 13 years or so and that's where we
are now and I've always lifted equipped
because when I started in the 90s gym
rat as we call it would lift heavy
weight in the gym but a power lifter
would put the gear on and go and compete
in a meet if they're a power lifter so
that's why I came up or knee wraps or
squat suit I wore a benchpress shirt
even in the 90s because everyone else
did now things have changed a little bit
because people think that the suits and
the shirts have gotten way too excessive
and way too complicated to use but I've
just evolved with the technology the
whole time while other people have taken
the gear off and lifted raw at the end
of the day it is all still powerlifting
it's just a bit of a different sport and
I can get into the pros and cons of each
- that would be that would be great one
thing that's interesting I have to say
because I don't know the lineage of
powerlifting sufficiently well I
presumed the equipt had come out of raw
what it appears that it's actually the
other way around
absolutely benchpress was invented at
bench pressure it was invented in
eighties Wow and everyone wore one
including including a lot of the people
that don't like gear now you know a lot
of people don't know that that you know
some of the best lifters ever mike
bridges Osby Alexander Lamar Gant ed
Cohen they wore gear they wore power
lifting gear they weren't near apps they
were suits
they were shirts sometimes so yes so
it's always been equipped now Fred
Hatfield dr. squat one of the first guys
in squat over a thousand pounds he
actually was known to kind of bend the
rules a little bit whether it be putting
tennis balls behind the knees or wearing
really tight jeans is lifted
so that's literally my reaction to
laughing yeah that's a laughing I have
when people talk about power them to be
in a pure sport I'm like you have no
idea they would have done anything back
then to lift more weight just like we're
doing now so to me the only level
playing field is where would you want to
wear yeah take what you want to take and
then come compete like a drag race you
know what I mean because otherwise the
testing is flawed that's why so many
people every couple years in the IPF are
booted out
they changed the weight classes they
change the records because the cops will
always be behind the robbers the
criminals they're always gonna find ways
to beat the drug test now you have rules
that are implemented the IPF where you
can't have someone assist you put on
your knees sleeves or elbow sleeves
because it helps you too much you have
to be able to put them on and take them
off by yourself because everyone has
been in the rules there are wearing
sleeves it took three people to put them
on they're getting 150 pounds on their
squats so that's not wrong to me but
again it's just my opinion the problem
there is that as you start to add layers
and layers of nuance and say you can't
this and you can't that everyone is
going to find a way to do those things
that you've now prohibited and that I I
agree I think what we've them I've heard
it on a million podcasts before people
saying I want to see how fast the
fastest man on the planet can run with
everything that he's got behind him with
his testosterone as high as he wants it
with his human growth hormone as high as
he wants it with all of the assistants
all the kit in a wind tunnel at what cuz
that's what you want to see at the XS
dreams and the limits of human
performance limiting anything to do with
it to me is if it's for safety I don't
know it's at that bit and you want to
point but definitely is a spectator of
the sport I want to see someone go as
fast lift as heavy that's why I want
there's been more hormones hittin
baseball this year and ever in history
this year at American baseball and even
more than the so-called steroid era and
the problem with that is people want to
see action they don't want to see a
pitcher's battle a pitcher's go they
want to see the ball hit hard and
that's what they want to see so you know
baseball suffered for a long time after
the so called steroid era and it died it
died a little bit it's coming back now
but also the common denominator is a lot
of people think they're wrapping the
baseball tighter
okjung the changing the bowl right it's
got coke Center or something now
well yeah they've changed a few things
about it and it's made the ball what
they call more lively where it jumps up
the bat further and a lot of pictures
are very mad about it because they
that's making their job harder
because it's harder to get people out no
one goes to the to the baseball we went
to a New York Yankees game recently on
the stag do in New York went to New York
Yankees game not a single I don't think
there was anything more than a double
that was here I'm like there for three
hours yeah I mean like come on you want
to get your buddies worth yeah that's
good and that's gonna be from seeing
action home runs doubles triples plays
it the plate action clashing yes that's
what you go to see exactly so there's a
there's a very good episode of Victor
Conti the guy behind BALCO on Joe Rogan
from about seven years ago it is
brilliant and it talks about how there's
no truly drug-free sports out there
there's always dirt I don't know if you
saw that I can't Ikaros or I'm curious
or whatever I have flicks it goes to
show you that everyone's doping to some
extent for the most part they're always
trying to beat the system if they're not
taking things that are prohibited
they're taking things that are almost
prohibited or a slight vert vert a
slight deviation of that chemical and
then they pass and then there's always
stuff and that's how Victor Conti
developed those designer steroids that
people forgot about then drug companies
have developed long ago and they weren't
on the banned list so he took them and
said hey these aren't banned let's go
fire that baseball blew up football blew
up track-and-field weightlifting all
that stuff did you might even notice
that the action stars were more muscular
back then - mm-hmm
Christian Bale is one of them Brad Pitt
is another they're all a lot more
muscular than
so I think a lot of people were dabbling
and that and taught me to get on a
tangent but this is an interesting
rabbit hole you know we talked about the
government and the bodies that be the
powers that be concerned about health
that's that's so hypocritical when they
allow alcohol sales and cigarette smells
or sells and tobacco and pharmaceuticals
that are killing people left and right
don't tell me that you drug test for the
safety of athletes when you allow all
these crazy things to be to be taken and
used that's the problem I have with it
because I think that the use of
performance-enhancing drugs is not I
wouldn't say it's safe but there's a lot
more dangerous things that we do and we
ingest on a regular basis and I know
lots of people that have taken
performance-enhancing drugs for twenty
and thirty years and they've literally
had no side effects other than a little
bit of stuff that will will happen blood
pressure will come up the cholesterol
will get out of whack but all of it
returns to normal when they come off of
it just like other medicines they will
screw you up for a little while you get
done what you need to then you come off
so I think that a lot of that's
overblown and that was exposed by real
sports with Bryant Gumbel about ten
years ago when they went and talked to
these doctors that research testosterone
and other performance-enhancing drugs
and they said there's a lot of medicinal
benefit to some of these as long as
they're taken properly and the dosage is
gonna reign range then the Taj is gonna
rain just like with any drug from person
to person so it really just depends so I
get why they want to clean up sports I
don't necessarily agree with why don't
say it's a safety concern that's silly I
think a fad play concerned seems to be a
good shout it allows you to have
contiguous records and stuff you're on
your right like if it wasn't happening
back then it's difficult to rate what's
happening now
have you seen I'm gonna guess that you
will have done Chris Bell's bring it
stronger faster yes yeah the antastic
documentary I don't think it's still
available on Netflix actually did you
watch prescription thugs which was the
Sikh yes and he's got a new one on that
leaf that plant leaf what's it called
crydom creative kratom yes he's got that
coming out soon although might not be
out might be up yeah anyway yeah bigger
stronger faster he says on that he has
this particular quote where he says they
litigated testosterone and other
performance-enhancing drugs to stop
cheating in sport and stopped ninety
nine percent of people taking it who
weren't cheating in sport because it's
the gym rat in the gym who wanted to get
big arms or someone who wanted to you
know there wasn't someone that was
competing in a professional organization
so on that point I think yeah I I agree
with what you say so getting back to
powerlifting itself and talking about
what the kit consists of now so we've
spoken about kind of the Heritage coming
up so you're you're gonna go do a meet
next week what's what's in your kit bag
and what are you putting on for what
lift and and why and what's it consist
of so for the squad I wear squat briefs
underneath squat ereefs yes quiet
breathe so they're they're like you know
their knee length or a little bit
shorter actually and they support the
hips okay and so it helps a bit now
different people get different amounts
out of each piece of gear and how much
they v to tune it how much they can
utilize it because you got to think when
you start putting restrictive clothing
on or restrictive apparel it changes the
groove if you let it you have to keep it
in the same groove so if the bar is
harder to bring down or the the bar is
harder to come down with on the squat
then that's another variable you have to
control you have to force yourself to
get down yet to stay tight your blood
pressure is up higher so I wear briefs
under the squat suit and I'm sponsored
by Ensor advanced design so I where they
Leviathan squat suit it's adjustable and
that allows me to on a any given day
when I've had when I have it tuned in
and locked locked in really nice I can
get another two hundred pounds over over
my Ross squat but with that said some
people I get fifty pounds but I've
mastered it I've mastered it to make my
equip squat as we call it the best
possible without compromising anything
else
don't care about my Ross squat when I'm
training for the meet that's the way I'm
trained for the last 20 years
all it matters is what you do in
competition and to me that that's that's
really the real support of powerlifting
the variables they're you know anyone
could literally someone that just
started lifting weights in the gym can
go and do it raw power lifted me that
doesn't take much skill they may not
lift very much weight but it doesn't
take any skill to squat 50 pounds to
bench 50 pounds or just the deadlift 20
you know 250 125 whatever it may be that
takes no skill now you add in gear and
equipment there has to be a bit of
pedigree and development of that skill
and harnessing it so it kind of
eliminates a lot of people that should
not be powerlifting from even trying it
so that's what I liked about it with
powerlifting being mainstream there's
pros and cons it used to be scary and a
lot of people didn't want to do it
because the people were crazy now it's
widely accepted and you know you can't
you can't look down on someone for being
a beginner I get all that stuff you
shouldn't but at the same time these
string sports aren't for everyone and I
think the the pendulum is swung and the
favor of anyone can do it everyone's
accepted all this stuff and I think it
should be a little more scary a little
more violent like it used to be in the
days of the chasm iron cone and Goggins
and all those guys and when I came up
and the nineties and early 2000s so
that's a little bit about the squat gear
and of course I wear a heavy duty
weightlifting belt to create that
stiffness and that intra-abdominal
pressure in the trunk and it's an art to
it man it's an art to be able to to hold
more weight than your body can actually
lift so you have to program and build
your search central nervous system so it
doesn't just shut off when you pick that
weight up on the squats because a lot of
people's lights go out on a big bench
press a big squat they go out because
they have too much blood pressure they
get lightheaded and they go out or they
they crumble because it's too much
pressure
what does it feel like physically what
not mentally yet what does it feel like
physically to have all of those layers
on is it just like being compressed down
an awful lot how does it feel to be in
this
what suit it's very uncomfortable and a
lot of people who have who've knocked it
the past haven't tried it and you know
an interesting tidbit is there's been a
lot of lifters that left equipped
lifting and went and did the raw did
really well I've yet to see more than a
couple lifters ever leave raw lifting
and come to equipped and dominate
there's only been a couple people do
that yeah and that's what I mean by the
skill if you can squat well in a squat
suit with all those variables you damn
sure squat well without all those things
so I advise everyone to start off raw
everyone to start off Frogg get the form
create those engrams and then from there
if you want to add equipment and so be
it but build the base level of strength
and have some technical proficiency
before you even worry about that what
does it feel like sometimes everything
in your body hurts no squats suits very
cumbersome so that's why you have to
stay calm
you know you have knee wraps on you have
a squat suit on you have to shimmy under
the bar you have to get tied you have to
pick the weight up and then you have to
squat with pristine form with all those
layers on so it's very difficult another
thing that people don't realize it's
hard to tell where you are depth wise so
you might think that you're going super
deep and you're still that much above
parallel so there's a lot of a lot of
variables there that add some difficulty
to it yeah
so that touches on a question that I
want you to ask I'm sure a lot of people
are thinking what what do you do before
a lift and what is the inside of your
head like before you're about to put
1,000 pounds on you back in a meet it's
it's really focused and I go to a dark
dark place in my head where I don't care
about anything else and the last thing I
want in the world to happen when I'm
under the bar is to miss the lifts and
embarrass myself so everything is
extremely tight I visualize and see the
lift being completed effortlessly before
I even approach the platform I already
see it happen I see the crowds reaction
and I strive for that feeling to happen
before it even happens so I get out
there and I just go to my default mode
I tune everything out I tuned everyone
out I go and lift and I fight for my
life for a couple seconds then I put it
back down then I try to breathe and
relax so you turn it on you turn it off
you turn it on you turn it off I like a
fighter UFC fighter between rounds you
got a chill
breathe and relax then you go you turn
it back on and you relax so it's a dark
place that I go to for sure I love
hearing about that the listeners who
heard the episode with Sony Webster
Olympic weightlifter
he said something interesting and I'm
gonna ask you the same he said that he
does the same before he steps up to the
to the platform he visualizes himself
completing the left he gets asked the
question often I wondered the same for
you do you visualize yourself doing it
from the first person or do you watch
yourself doing it from behind the stage
both okay interest I'll watch myself
from the crowd yeah I see myself in the
crowd how I'm gonna look how I look so
sturdy
I'll look so sturdy and stuff on the
squat that as soon as I pick it up
everyone in the crowd knows that I'm
gonna crush the weight I see that happen
I go through the squat I come up I grind
through it if I have to and then I know
I've already done a dry run in my head I
go out there and do it I also see myself
doing it picking up the weight feel
myself doing it so I look at it from all
perspectives it's not interesting that
we we view it for some reason we decide
to view it from not ourselves we look at
it from someone else I think that's
really I don't know I don't know what
that is about about prep but obviously
you know some of the best athletes in
the world in the world choose to to use
that so moving a bit sir I think it's
self-awareness - mm-hmm it's a bit of
self-awareness that comes with the
maturity of lifting and you want to be
you want to you know what is expected up
there on the platform you know when
someone is up there and they know what
they're doing that's what you expect
from yourself so you automatically want
to see that from yourself I think I
don't know that's a little weird but
it's good interesting if you've got any
any ideas or if you someone listening
who has a any more information feel free
to got me so you mentioned that the
1,100
and 85 pound squat cost you yes can you
tell us what and why so I had squatted
11:30 just before that squat and I
wanted to go for the all-time world
record of 1180 so I had to beat that by
5 pounds or 2 kilos so I was feeling
good I figured I could get to lift as I
was doing the lift it it's the heaviest
weight I've ever picked up and I saw
stars I saw black spots everywhere when
I picked it up it was very heavy and I
was like here we go I came up with it as
I was locking out my left leg stopped
working a bit and I had a hard time
locking it all the way up and at that
time I felt like I rehearse or damaged
something pretty bad and that cost me a
bit because my lifting started to
regress after that lived a little bit
and so I got with dr. McGill and got
that figured out but I knew that I'd
messed something up as soon as I got
from underneath the squat and walked
away I knew I got a little bit forward a
little bit bent forward with it and I
got out of position which cost me but
still stood it up still stood up still
got credit for it and had to get
basically helped off the platform after
that and I still finished the meat did
well but uh yeah that that I left a
little bit of something of myself out
there that day I'm not interesting so
moving on to the progression of the
regression I suppose we could call it
from that point up to when you sat down
we've talked to McGill also there's a
story but when you're in a parking lot
as well which I think a lot of people
might be interested to hear so you had
so I'll ask you do you think that there
was any other significant acute episodes
other than that particular squat or was
it cumulative over time is it just
volume and volume and volume and there
is a lot of things I think the first
first incident was in 10th Grade I was
running the stadiums that I tweaked my
back a little bit the second in such
1995 or 96 the second incident that I
had was in 2003 I straight my back a
little bit I felt a pop
I was dead lifting that settled after a
little while then in 2009 I was on an
obstacle course I was trying out for a
scholarship the police department and I
was the first person to run that warning
and it was 8 o'clock in the morning on
that July July day so we had a lot of
humidity and as I was jumping over a
barricade there's do all over it and I
slipped and landed right on my butt my
back like that and that's when I was
laying in the parking lot afterward my
legs weren't working and I barely was
able to drive myself home
it took everything I had but like any
brilliant athlete like myself I I did my
first 1,100 squat name and our deadlift
about three weeks after that so that's
just to kind of answer your question I
did a lot of stupid stuff and I just
kept pushing like I was Superman and
finally in 2011 that big lift that was
another little thing that chipped away
at it and then 2012 about eight months
after that 1185 squat I was warming up I
was on pace to squat 1200 at this meet
and when I was warming up I felt my back
go
I felt man a lot of burning sensation
locally in my lumbar spine and I had a
very very very much battle through that
mean I ended up wedded that one but my
back started regressing so that was 12
and then 13 he got really bad and that's
when I finally gave up after seeing
multiple neurosurgeons more multiple
orthopedic surgeon that got my shots you
know people get these shots these these
facet joint injections nerve root blocks
the problem is if you're not removing
the cause they're totally useless
because it's only a numbing sensation so
until you remove the cause of the pain
and build more pain-free capacity those
epidurals are useless so I went through
that thinking they're just magically
gonna cure me then I went down the path
of trying to get surgery thinking that
would just be I'm gonna go ahead and get
surgery then everything's gonna be great
and that's not the way it works and
thank God my client suggested I see dr.
McGill and within a month I was there
with them in his laboratory it's eight
crazy to think of speaking to dr. McGill
and also having read back mechanic and a
fair chunk of the gift of injury your
book with him as well
surgery appears to be a very very rapid
option
I think perhaps a little more so in
America in fact I was with dr. McGill
when he took a phone call from a lady
who said she'd had back pain for eight
days had been to see a consultant and
the consultant had said we need to get
you in for surgery and I'm thinking to
herself you've had back pain for eight
days like that could be anything you
could have like a splinter in your back
like you literally could sat on a bit of
wood so yeah the the root of surgery dr.
McGill went through a number of the
reasons why that's a bad idea in his
estimation I think this that is now our
80% of back surgeries are back to the
same baseline level of pain within 12
months yeah I think that's a roundabout
right yeah so you didn't you didn't go
for that you went to go see dr. McGill
and split sacrum front to back l4 l5 and
l5 s1 are just obliterated I think was
the terminology that he yes and from
there what happened because you're used
to doing deadlift and squat on a Monday
and bench on a Wednesday and all this
sort of stuff and dr. dr. McGill does
the thing where he pushes his mustache
to one side and he looks at you he looks
at you like this and then he gets his
finger out and he points at you and what
does he what does he say he says that my
spine hygiene is terrible it's not of a
top athlete so I had to reprogram the
way I moved and that meant squatting so
everything I did when I'm sitting in a
chair I'm standing up pushing my hips
through then when I sit down about
clapping mm-hmm
sitting down easily so I had to get the
hip hinge down the same way you push
yourself off the toilet I had to learn
to lunge to tie my shoes so for instance
it's here put my foot up on a chair and
then lean forward and lunge into it
mmm-hmm did the last thing as a golfers
pick up where you basically stand on one
leg and then reach down with the nice
and flat back all I was doing was
bending flexion underload further
perpetuating my injury and picking the
scab every day so you have a lot of
people and I was included I would do a
reverse hyper so I would do lumbar
stretches the silly stretches he calls
them I'd pull my knee to my chest I'd
bend down and touch my toes which is not
inherently bad but it is bad for a
powerlifter especially one with back
pain now if you're trying to be a
gymnast those stretches are probably
gonna help you or maybe they might help
you right but you've got to pick if you
want to be a power lifter you have to
tune the body to be a power lifter if
you want to be a gymnast you need a lot
of flexibility but don't expect that
strength out of it just like the power
lifter shouldn't expect that mobility
out of their back you have to you have
to choose wisely with every exercise
that you put in a program so I was doing
the reverse Hyper's I was doing this
stretching I was doing weighted sit-ups
I was basically creating the perfect
recipe for a painful back so I know
you'd be very surprised Chris but as
soon as I removed the hammer the hammer
that was always nailing my my prank my
pain triggers I felt a lot better within
a couple of days in my pain wound way
down of us immediately can you take us
from what was the arts daily was a 8 out
of 10 was 7 out of 10
where'd it go - it was an 8 within 24
hours and even a couple hours in the lab
it went down to like a 3 of just me
being conscientious of okay sitting up
properly not leaning forward not bending
within a couple hours it felt a whole
lot better and within a couple of days
it was down to about a 2 or a 1
how did I after being in so much pain
for so long it was a huge relief my wife
couldn't believe it because she came
along for the ride and she said you
haven't talked about your back hurting
one time since you left dr. McGill and I
said I know it's crazy
and and I like to share this information
with people to know that they can get
out of pain
the problem is they're too blind to see
how simple it really is they think they
have to take this medicine they think
that the back surgeons are the end-all
be-all they're really they're designed
to do one thing and that's the cut on
you and like dr. McGill says and he
probably explained to you they're not
likely to go in there and cut your only
pain trigger out a lot of time there's
multiple pain triggers there's no
guarantee they're gonna get that one and
and and likely they're gonna open you up
they're gonna destabilize your back that
might fuse it together and then the the
above and below of the fusions gonna
suffer after that I I've yet to meet
more than a couple people that have ever
had a less than one back surgery there's
always more that followed there's always
more because you know what they don't
remove the cause have you ever met
someone who's been through back surgery
and has come back to be athletically
capable yes I have met but they had
three surgeries yeah
and they still are inhibited in certain
ways because they don't have they're
locked up they have a spinal fusion so
they've had three fusions and the first
one didn't take the second one ended up
reversing itself and the screws came
loose the third one took but they have a
lot of struggles and a lot of pain daily
they come and go because you know what
when you cut through those nerves and
you cut through that musculature
sometimes it's never the same again
they're nervous might reattach somewhere
else and then you have weird pain
randomly so there's a lot that that
you're risking when you let someone open
you up like that that doesn't understand
how the spine is supposed to work it's
not supposed to be a bending rod like
that unless you're turning it for it to
be that and the PT's just blindly
prescribing stretching or really hurting
a lot of people when they when they get
them out of surgery or refer to it to PT
to prevent surgery they just further
complicated a lot of the time yeah
what's the quote from the gift of injury
do not go open that which God designed
to stay closed yes that is what a
anesthesiologist surgeon told me because
I always wanted to get back
and you know what avoid back surgery
avoided it all cost because I have
colleagues that do it and they are not
successful and it's gonna further
complicate everything and that's when he
used that line keep it closed and
actually this weekend I saw a couple
people had seen in a while both of them
worked for a back surgeon I'm sorry they
worked for a medical device company that
works alongside surgeons for spinal
fusions and he said dude you do not want
these surgeons they messed them up all
the time and they my friends are they
work alongside the surgeons to ensure
that the tools are using did they sell
them are being utilized properly he said
man these surgeons mess up all the time
you do not want to ever get it back
surgery little do they know I already
knew all that yeah you don't
I've spoken to patient zero dr. Stewart
Miguel himself he knows all of this
stuff so moving forward from you've had
your consultation you're now at least a
little bit less pain free but you're not
able to get under a bar without pain I'm
gonna guess and start squatting so what
was the next few months the next year
like after that consultation with dr.
Miguel so it was all about discipline it
was desensitizing and removing the cause
there was a lot of Magill big three and
a lot of walking for a couple months and
then eventually when the pain was
totally gone I called him up and he said
well you're pain free that was my job
now it's your job to get back to the
platform so I took that on and I learned
a lot and thankfully because of me
learning how to progress from stage one
ever moving the cause to building
pain-free capacity and so on and so
forth I've become pretty well-versed and
helping other people progress they they
need to read back mechanic and gift of
injury to find their pain triggers and
to remove them once they remove them I
can show them how to implement the
exercises to build them back and I do
that with a lot of people I'm actually a
McGill provider now for Florida is the
clinician yeah so I see a lot of people
here in Florida for their pain and again
the prerequisite is Rita's reading back
mechanic and
of injury that way uncovered they need
to they need to diagnose himself they
need to remove the cause that I can help
them train as a trainer getting back to
sport and where that may be so for me it
was a lot of McGill 3 a lot of carries a
lot of walking and his perfect spine
hygiene whether it be sleeping moving
working traveling every single day and
what this did was put dollars in my bank
accounts I'm hearing I'm hearing the
McGill accent just pouring out here it's
so I put I put deposits in the bank
account so when so I saw him in May so
when November rolled around I had enough
to start withdrawing so I put it in
outside of the gym so I could pull it
out inside of the gym and so once I
progressed from the carries and such I
added in goblet squats I didn't an
elevated deadlifts and rack pulls then
eventually by November I was getting
back to the competition lifts and then I
think by January I squatted over a
thousand pounds again pain-free and I
still had a couple roads to cross and
hurdles to jump over as I went to
compete in March that was ten months
after seeing McGill I was just flat out
too big I got too big too heavy and at
the meet I was actually winning it and
going into the deadlift my back got
grumpy on me
and so I pulled out of the meet I didn't
finish that was a blow to my ego because
the whole year after that I'd been
working on getting back getting pain
free you know
excuse me and a lot of people had saved
my progress right and it was
disappointing to me that I wasn't able
to finish so Stu and I devised the plan
where I would drop some body weight and
I would build more capacity by squatting
bitching and dead lifting all in the
same day that would simulate the meat so
you got to get into a little bit of
extension when you're squatting a little
bit of flexion sometimes a little bit
and then a lot of extension on the squad
bench and then a little bit of flexion
and extension on the deadlift so I was
able to build more tolerance and more
athleticism slowly and then if I felt
like I was
to our dad back off so I was really in
tune with my body by then and then
within the next few months I had a
personal record at a lighter weight
class better than injury pre-injury and
then I won the Arnold two more times
after that with better lifts post injury
than I did pre injury you see touched on
ego that and the fact that you had to
say no to this deadlift going back to
the first few months because there will
be a lot of people listening and I'm one
of them I'm personally interested I've
recently seen dr. McGill there will be
other people out there who will be
suffering with an injury and they may
have been prescribed a course of
rehabilitation which requires them to
take a big slice of humble pie negative
to swallow an awful lot of ego so for
you one of the strongest men on the
planet how did it feel did you have any
trouble with that or was your goal to
become pain-free what did you see this
as a part of your journey or were there
some questions in their way you began to
get frustrated and stuff like that when
you were doing bird bird dog for you
know ten minutes a day and side plank
for 10 minutes a day etc etc it was a
blow to my ego but I looked at it this
way nothing was more devastating to me
than losing my athleticism so after
trying to do it by way researching on my
own thinking I knew everything getting
their shots getting the consult I caved
and when I talked with dr. McGill I was
a little skeptical about what he had to
say and then after a little while I
realized that he knew what he was
talking about so when I met him and that
man that on that May Day in 2013 I went
into his lab as a complete beginner I
went in there like I knew nothing and
the only thing I held tight to
concerning my ego and my pride was that
I'm gonna compete again everything else
I turned over to him completely now I've
met a lot of athletes that are world
class world record holders you name it
that are done now because they couldn't
step away from the barbell or step away
from the track or the Octagon and get
pain free now I've met a lot of people
that say they can't do it
for a variety of reasons and what I say
to that is biology is very binary it
doesn't care about your mental state it
doesn't care about what you have going
on your bills either your giving
yourself enough stimulus to build and be
better or you're tearing your body down
and so if you can't stop lifting for the
sake of your mental health or your
wallet then I wouldn't expect to get out
of paint
and that's what that's what I tell them
and then they go on and have a surgery
thinking they can just get their pain
cut out and they're good and then they
never return back to the platform or the
Octagon or the track or whatever it may
be so it's very hard for a lot of people
because there's a lot of stress going on
right now throughout the world with the
climate social media everyone's wound up
and fighting and and so they use
exercise for an outlet to de-stress and
when you take that away from them they
freak out well you can still walk you
can still do your core work but you're
gonna have to take time away from going
out there and draw on the barbell every
day so it was hard but once I got going
cuz I I've caught some I caught some
stuff from friends when I wasn't lifting
and I would still go to the gym everyday
but I'd be doing my big ill three and my
carries and all that stuff so I didn't
care the way I looked at it was this I'd
beat just about every one of the past
and I was doing what I needed to do to
get back there once again and I'd get
the last laugh well fantastic philosophy
fantastic philosophy I mean when you are
one of the strongest men on the planet
that's the sort of thing that you can
say but I hope that that has reframed
for a lot of people that might be
listening just the sort of sacrifices
that you do need to make I've certainly
having seen dr. McGill and I sent him a
couple of emails afterwards just asking
for some clarity on some of the
prescriptions that he'd given me moving
forward one of these questions asked the
asked something which I shouldn't have
asked which was can I go to failure on
any of these /so I should do you have an
R PE or reps and sets like suggestion
because that's the language that I talk
in that's one that's all I've known I've
known what how hard should I go on
and it was
TRX ring Rose push-ups front rack
kettlebell carry and single leg knee
raise how hard should I go can I go to
failure and I just got this email back
and I was it was just like he shouted at
me it was there wasn't any capital
letters but it was in quite big text and
it was just Chris you are talking like a
bodybuilder you want this is not the
route to get pain-free you need to be
focusing on movement quality first and
foremost I have had athletes who have
done nothing but xxx for six months to
one year to two years before they move
on to anything
etc etc etc and I was just I'm like okay
yes oh I have I have a lot of athletes
that I work with through online coaching
and I get them to read back we can't get
in read gift of injury and ultimate back
and then once they get paid free I
progressed some but sometimes they
relapse and that might be because the
new stress in their life they may have
gained some weight they may have lost
some weight there's a lot of things that
change you know our body is ever
evolving and adapting so sometimes
they're on a very light regimen for a
year and they think that ten weeks of
working with me is gonna cure everything
and I'm thinking man some flare-ups can
last three months or longer you know and
I mean if the nerve is really pissed off
so it takes time and there's no magical
wand there's no magic bullet it's all
about removing the cause and giving your
time your body time to let biology do
its thing and you can't contradict it
with things that don't are not cohesive
and that's a big thing that I think a
lot of people miss concerning your
question about RPE and my experience
what's so funny just the fact that I ask
that question to just whatever nothing
back to the email I just I think about
how in trouble I was don't worry I get I
get corrected all the time - don't worry
about it
okay I'm still learning so yeah I don't
feel bad about that I sometimes I'll
send something to of it like that was
stupid why don't I even say that
yeah that's that's you can't take
yourself too seriously you're gonna mess
up right especially to the The Godfather
right so in my experience with my
athletes in my lifting the lion's share
of your gains are gonna be made between
seventy percent or a seven RPE with
three reps left in the tank so about 85
percent or at eight and a half our PE
with one to two reps left in the tank
because when you go to failure a lot of
things happen number one you're not
happy about it you know if you're going
for a max rep set and you want five reps
with 200 kilos and you only get four and
you've melt you fail and miss on the
fifth one that kind of crushes your day
it ruins your day a little bit so pick
your times when you push and go after
numbers other times you want to train
and not test training and testing or
weigh different things when you go to
failure you're testing you're going to
the absolute limit or your body to find
out where you are too much testing is
problematic so again 70 to 85 percent of
your max on a given day is the sweet
spot you can get a lot of volume in
there you're not going to be missing
anything and then then you know you
could pick your days where you go 100%
but it's got to be few and far between
I understand one cushion I've been
thinking actually do you guys have any
walk outs like very very heavy walk outs
yes yes so we'll do heavy pickups heavy
walk outs will do overload sets so one
good thing about powerlifting is Louis 7
specifically he's really changed the
game for strength training in the
National Football League here with
American football with the baseball
players with college football power
lifters have showed that barbell use and
implementation is not just gonna take
away your athleticism you know what I
mean you need to you know assess the
demands for the sport but at the same
time weightlifting isn't just as
dangerous thing when it's done right so
it's pretty cool to see a lot of the
things that we do and in powerlifting
have carried over to all the sports you
know Louis Evans has done a great job at
that one thing that we've done and I've
utilized for a long time as a reverse
banned method and I
got that from Lois Simmons he calls it
the light method I also got it from Rick
Hussey a big iron Jim a legendary
powerlifting coach what you do is are
the squat and hang the bands from the
top the top of the rack and you hook it
around the barbells so as you go down
the load gets lighter as you come back
up it returns to its normal weight so
what that teaches you is to pick it up
and not be scared of the weight you
adjust to that load and the pressure
then as you go down to the lower you go
the lighter it gets and as you turn it
around it comes out of the bands that's
almost like a training wheel for a new a
new exercise or a new weight and we do a
lot of those that are really good for
tuning the central nervous system that's
really interesting
holds negatives pauses all the tempo all
that stuff has its proper time for for
implementation but one of the biggest
things that I'd like to tell the
listeners out there is you have to be
able to ask yourself an answer why am i
doing this exercise and if you can't
answer that you need to remove it
because I see people all the time
they'll send me their programming
they'll say what do you think about this
Brian and I'll say well it looks pretty
good but why are you doing the one-leg
Bulgarian split squat uh well I saw my
favorite lifter that's a bad answer to
say that what you should say is I want
to work on my quads a little bit more
you know for the squat lockout or for
the deadlift lockout or off the floor
I'm doing pause squats because I need
more explosiveness I'm doing speed work
because I'm slow I'm a good grinder but
I'm not good at exploding out of the
hole and these things can be taught so
your program needs to be built around
that your weaknesses and everything that
I do I can answer specifically as to why
I do them or why I have my clients do
them and I think that's half the battle
right there
so it needs to be built around
weaknesses but also around education of
the athlete by the coach is that right
yep yeah you know that it never doing
exercises just because they're hard or
at random everything's needs to be
specific to the needs of that lete and
for you it might be a hundred eighty
degrees opposite of what I need you know
you look like you're a really
guy you know you stay in good shape I
don't think you need to restrict your
calories anytime soon he on the other
hand I'll put on some body fat this year
right yeah you're lean I'm not so lean
right now so for me just to say Chris
and Brian and everyone needs eat 4,000
calories today but no yeah I'll get fat
you may need that but not to get fat
yeah so that's what I mean like you have
to be able to answer these questions
because they're so important it's not
just a one-size-fits-all
rehab training program diet
supplementation it has to be customized
that's a really good way to to comment
on the coach and athlete dynamic I
certainly know a lot of people who were
at both ends of the spectrum right I
know some athletes who understand and
I'm one of them I'm inquisitive even if
it's not I'm questioning what my coach
is putting in as to question the
validity of it I just want to know that
okay so why why have I got this
particular movement in or why we're
using that time domain or why are we
doing this particular number of reps
just um I'm interested well learn I also
know people on the other end of the
spectrum who just want the prescription
that's put in front of them and they
just want to go through with it so I
guess again you know for the coaches
that I'm sure will be listening out
there that's something that you're gonna
need to take on as well right you're
gonna need to death what's the the
particular absorption rate of mental
space for my client and how much info
can I give them to get them educated yes
you got to think objectively for sure
and man the key is like you said some
people they want you to hand up the fish
other people want you to give them the
fishing pole right the people that want
the fishing pole are an eight they're
innately wired to be coaches I think
because they want to learn I just don't
want to be spoon fed it has success they
want to be able to replicate that
success and my and my experience so the
people they're asking questions
those are gonna be the future leaders
are not just the followers fantastic
Brian I will be linking back mechanic
gift of injury is there anything else if
anyone's interested wants to find out
some more info why would you say they
should go to power rack strength calm
that's where we have the others
that you named we also sell them on
Amazon back FitPro calm kabuki string
calm so we have a bunch of different
outlets where you can get those books I
personally from Pyrex string comm ship
worldwide anyone wants those but for a
lot of content that goes above and
beyond the books that we've talked about
my website Powerex drink has a lot of
articles that I've written over the last
five or six years that are there and
they're free so all of that along with
my my training philosophy is called 1020
life and that's the book that I sell
concerning my my strength training
philosophy and there's bits of it and
gift of injury a lot of it actually but
the strength manual itself without the
rehab without my story is 220 life but
I'm on social media Brian Carroll 81 on
Instagram and Facebook and I mean I
really enjoyed this conversation I say
conversation cuz it's what I felt like
it not just a podcast I really enjoyed
talking to you I'm located in
Jacksonville Florida anytime you want to
come over or if you're in this States
come I've got a full training center
here in my garage well my wife's let me
deck it out I got two mono lifts a
deadlift platform to competition benches
a rack a belt squat a lifting platform
that's that's competition grade
kettlebells 250 kilos and dumbbells up
to 80 kilos do you ever leave the house
I need to leave the house every once
where I get food but I get to the food
shipped here too but I want to thank you
for coming on I want to thank dr. McGill
for everything my sponsor ends our
advanced designs and Jack's nutrition I
appreciate all the help that I've gotten
and I can say that the last six years of
having the chance to meet dr. McGill
it's really helped my ego it's helped my
pride it's helped me to be more grateful
thankful for my athleticism and I wish
I'd have known this in my 20s so I could
have embraced it a little bit more but
I'm in a good place now so I'm grateful
for everything that's happened I'm so
happy for you man it's really it's
really lovely to hear that story of
redemption I'm gonna be following this
journey to a 1200 pound squat I'm sure a
lot of the listeners will be you'll have
gained a lot of new fans today you're
incredibly gracious and I think for a
a such a terrifying man on a lifting
platform your incredibly incredibly
humble and easy to talk to office so
thank you so much for coming on
everything that brian has mentioned
today will be linked in the show notes
below as always make sure that you get
em if there's any questions you've got
you know what I find me at Chris will
acts on all social media like share
subscribe do all that good stuff but for
now Brian thank you so much man thank
you it's been a pleasure
[Music]
you